also für diesen Einsatz müsst ihr das
auf jeden Fall bis zum Ende schauen ich
habe mich alleine auf den Weg nach
Thailand gemacht und so ging es für mich
weiter von Frankfurt aus bin ich nach
Bangkok geflogen habe dann dort zwei
Tage verbracht und habe mich dazu
entschieden einige Inseln im Golf von
Thailand abzuchecken also ging es für
mich von Bangkok nach Koh Samui dort
gibt's zum Flughafen und der erste
Eindruck war wirklich crazyten absolut
geil Kranke Insel und entfernt jeglicher
Vorstellung von all dem was ich vorher
gesehen habe wirklich einen traumhaftes
Paradies Koh Samui ist auf jeden Fall
perfekt um die Natur zu erleben und um
abends auch Party zu machen da geht
wirklich immer was also kann ich nur
jedem empfehlen das mal auschecken
dort habe ich ein paar Tage verbracht
und bin jetzt mittlerweile auf das ist
eine andere kleine Insel die ist so
ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden entfernt wir
sind auch super viele Europäer so in
meinem Alter und ja auf jeden Fall echt
sehr entspannt und der Ausblick war auch
schon mal schlecht da